[Music]
[Music]
well good afternoon good luck little one
[Music]
weirdo
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
it's the most extraordinary thing I've
ever seen he's not a sled dog he's a
lead dog you should have seen him
every single one of them he's
magnificent a future champion there's
blood you were right he's got the heart
of a survivor I'm going to name him
don't go after the Admiral an underdog
named for an underdog of a governess
people have worked this all out but by
all accounts when Seppala arrives at
Chateau look tomorrow the serum will be
there waiting for him he's in check
Toolik now or past it what no no no no
that's not possible
I know my husband if there's ice on
Norton Sound he's crossed it in this
storm sure he's not gonna try and cause
of course he would going around the
sound is 90 miles crossing it is 20 he
saves a day each way George if there's
ice on the sound he's crossing and if
they don't meet at the Roadhouse then
they'll they'll just hook up on the
trail there are a thousand ways a driver
can miss another on the trail a thousand
ways in good weather you know this I do
if my husband doesn't magically run into
your relay team the one he's not even
looking for he and his dogs will drive
on Friday Donna and your relay driver
when he realizes he's missed them he
will set out on his own
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
Oh
[Music]
good dog next time I go the wrong way
you told me to go to help good dogs all
intelligence
stamina
courage and heart my business is dogs
he's under sized is trouble
well good afternoon is untrainable
what does he bring to the breed the
heart of a survivor
he outran every single one of them he's
not a sled dog he's the lead dog
what we have in our children was an
epidemic the death sentence they found a
cure round trip is six hundred miles you
see that storm in the horizon only one
man and one dog can make that run he's
12 years old he's too old he'll never
make that distance
that when warned you pumpkin
[Music]
my guess is we don't find him till the
fall
all right Togo time for us to find out
who we are
I always thought he lived for the sled
when all along
[Music]
what he lived for
was me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the movie Togo is based on a true story
it had a lot of elements that are
attracted to my experience shooting
conditions a real relationship between
man and animal
Amanda nature there it comes the most
interesting stories come from people
that overcame really difficult
circumstances one of the greatest untold
stories of the 20th century
[Music]
during the greatest storm of 1925
children in Alaska were dying from
diphtheria all those to me we know them
this one man his dog sled team tried to
bring serum from over 600 miles away no
airplanes can come in the sea is frozen
so they're traveling with hundreds and
hundreds of miles and bitter cold
through tundra and frozen waterways why
does this man take this journey when
he's not sure they will survive he sees
indeed the thing that he loves to do can
maybe help other people
that's what heroism is
[Music]